let's talk about psyllium husk the uses
the dosage and potential side-effects
and what to do to counter that
so psyllium seed comes from the plant
plant hago Omata
and psyllium out of all the fibers has
the most soluble fiber which means when
you add water it gels up so it's the gel
effect that stimulates the peristalsis
or the pumping action of the large
intestine so you can eliminate better
so if psyllium seed is mainly used as a
laxative it's good for constipation
irritable bowel syndrome high blood
pressure heart disease I'm gonna put
some links down below of the research so
you can see also it's good for diabetes
it has the potential to significantly
reduce blood sugars after eating and
number six it can reduce cholesterol now
the amount that you would need in a
given day would be about seven grams a
day and you would mix that with water
and drink it on down
so you want to make sure that you
consume more water to decrease these
side effects right here and if you ever
noticed when you eat a big salad a lot
of times you're thirsty that's because
the body is telling you we need more
water to create that gel effect now
another side effect from psyllium seed
would be having an allergy to it okay
also psyllium seed has a potential of
decreasing iron in your body which it
actually is not really a problem for
most people because most people have too
much iron also it has potential of
decreasing vitamin b2 and decreasing the
absorption of fat and if you have
constipation and you want the complete
list of some of the best natural
remedies for constipation check out this
video on this page